namenlos lauf schneller logo [ __ ]
scheiße hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem hunger games mit
radu event das ganze wird hier von
nitrat ich sag mal vorbereitet und zwar
ist dass dieses franck sarrazin finals
von dem nitrat und zwar konnte man sich
dafür in vielen spielen qualifizieren
ich habe mich ja auch versucht zu
qualifizieren hat allerdings nicht
geschafft deswegen bin ich jetzt nur
kommentator und kann hier nur sage ich
mal mit zuschauern kommentieren usw
nebenbei mit mir kommentieren also so
wie ich wird kälte mio gbp wird zwar
noch machen und noch irgendein anderer
youtuber den ich aber nicht kenne
hier sind sehen jetzt gerade der staat
ist gerade angefangen wir laufen einfach
mal den dort ab hinterher weil der ja in
den letzten runden immer sehr ich sag
mal sehr gut gewonnen hat also sehr wie
kann ich das sagen wie kann ich das
nennen reicht auch mal schon sehr mit
großem abstand sag ich mal gut ich bin
natürlich invisible für die ganzen leute
also die können mich hier nicht sehen
ich fliege einfach nur so ein bisschen
mit rum es gibt auch leute die am teams
gemacht und an dieser stelle nochmal
danke an nitrat kann die leute die da
bei nitrat arbeiten und das ganze
organisiert haben also das echt eine
super sache was hier gemacht haben der
see ist der rolle der wird das mit hier
kommentieren ich weiß nicht was seinem
youtube kanal ist oder wie er heißt oder
keine ahnung ich bin immer noch auf der
suche nach debitor sie ihr seht hier die
ganzen leute hier drauf sind und ja gut
wir können das jetzt einfach mal hier
mit kommt hier nicht kann ich einmal so
ein bisschen nicht die map zeigen
also wer jetzt nicht sehen will wie ich
einfach rumfliegen erfahrung
ob jetzt habe ich das nicht dass man da
liegen probst das tut mir leid
die map ist wirklich episch gebaut es
gibt vier verschiedene es ist halt der
netter und es gibt hier verschiedene
dinge die wirklich gebaut wurden zum
beispiel hier brunnen usw suche die
kiste da muss man hier die kiste suchen
werden könnten die sein
dies war bestimmt irgendwie da dahinter
der lava oder soweit ich kann einfach
gucken
ach was sag ich schon ausgeflogen
man kann halt wirklich überall hin es
gibt ja schon die wildesten kämpfe wie
zum beispiel gerade da wird schon wieder
jemand gepanscht von dorothee achter ist
der spieler der ruhr oder web will er
immer vorne
ich konnte ihr das einfach mal so ein
bisschen mit daher glaube ich ja nix
gegen der will kann abschalten wenn das
nicht interessiert also ich möchte das
einfach nur ein bisschen fördern sag ich
mal also damit ihr irgendwie bei nitrat
mal vorbeischaut ist auf jeden fall eine
ganz ganz coole sache was sich
organisiert haben
danke für den sehr stabilen server
wahrscheinlich hatten oder ob lecks und
meint das ironisch so da hinten sind
zwei die machen wahrscheinlich ein team
die haben auch schon die gleichen sachen
weil sie den gleichen skin damit man
sieht wo gern zusammen der einheit schon
ein hemmnis interessant der banane
griffen ineinander griffen ist ein
interessanter namen oder kann ja du
musst darauf genau jetzt da hoch jetzt
wieder so schräg oder das auftreten des
mpeg wenn ja da hört mich nicht und
sieht mich nicht aber einfach mal so ein
bisschen rum auch interessant dass sich
grundsatz da gerade gar nicht hier sehr
weil sie die gehen gar nicht hier
hierbei sind sage ich mal ich gucke
einfach noch ein bisschen mit rum
hier ist mit kisten kästen back dies
offen und keine ahnung
mitchell ist kann ich auch gucken ob ich
habe keine access ihr seid ein großer
serveranbieter da muss man doch mal ein
vernünftiges server aufbauen können denn
weder ist jetzt einfach traurig weil er
verloren hat oder eine wie keine ahnung
eigentlich geht es auch so wenig schiff
rechtsweg mache kann ich einem zugucken
der ist allerdings auch spectator das
heißt dem kann ich schlecht zu gucken da
als ein spieler jetzt mehrere spieler
und das wird jetzt interessant dass er
jetzt interessant ist auch die beiden
machen team weg hier
sarah tom cruise bitte komme bescherten
probleme bitte per e mail an support
radio ist schön auch gut dass sie sich
wirklich um ihre fans sage ich mal
kümmern oder um die leute die hier die
server haben
ich kann euch das immer ganz gut zeigen
wie das hier uns abgelaufen ist also
jetzt fragen sich bestimmt auch leute
was sollen das konnte jeder bist doch in
den dingen sda rausgeflogen warum kannst
du ja trotzdem noch mitmachen
ich mache ja nicht mit sondern ich
fliege ja wiederum und beobachtet das
habe leider kann man in eine falle
gelaufen
ich mache ja nicht mit sondern ich filme
sehr einfach nur hier ist bin ich
gespannt da konnte man da halt zu den
stellen anlaufen
da musste man ein recht machen und dann
ist man da unten das war dann ein
turnier mit 24 spielern was außerdem bei
brawngp und sah in dem livestream
aufgenommen wurde also die haben dort
mitgespielt
ok und scheinen meinen viele dass bei
ihm gelebt hat aber ich weiß es nicht
als ich meinen die anderen die sind
bisher alle noch im spiel haben die
entweder deren internet oder ich glaub
nicht dass am nitrat server liegt weil
wenn sie wird die hamster mit 100 slots
also der tipp auf jeden fall gut
ausgerüstet kann ich nicht irgendwie
respekt spec thate spektakel 333 geht
nicht konkret tabelle sprays okay jetzt
bin ich unsicher
okay gut also wie viele sind dann
ungefähr noch so einem leben catering
sind konnte sarrazin nicht mehr als
nicht mit als figuren hier dachte aber
gut
naja hier sind noch welche dateien
coolen skin muss ich sagen ich werde
jetzt auch gar nicht wie lange ich das
noch berichten werde
ganze blitze die nerven das liegt
einfach alles nicht mal minecraft drohen
sehr sehr leid tut auch nichts durch das
kartell läuft einfach so mit rum
hh der lüfter okay der er lebt noch und
der fliegt auch noch rum da und lässt
eine hh und wie geht's aus wie geht's
aus
wahrscheinlich hätten hier o'brien skin
wahrscheinlich wartet er darauf dass der
andere ihn wieder runterkommt da kann
sich das ganze dann mal ganz schön an
also wenn ich er wäre ich würde da nicht
runtergehen
ich würde echt nicht machen wollt ihr
alle
der andere hing achtbester hinten
gelaufen und das macht er hier an der
star wird interessantes battle hier wird
sehr interessant und der versteckt sich
da jetzt einfach oder wie das ist ja
witzig cooler typ
köln karten kann man auch nicht nehmen
ich glaube sein job ist ziemlich
verärgert darüber dass er draußen ist
wie ihr sicherlich amtszeit beschwert
naja gut darum deshalb klar es steht ja
immer noch rum also das ist ein lied
rado admin hier unten laufen die richtig
rum oder sind die auch schon am fliegen
ich weiß es gar nicht die ersten beiden
von vorhin die immer noch am leben sind
vestas der 8 mio
wie viele teams es hier gibt wie viele
leben noch bitte wiederholung also ich
glaube nicht dass sie das wiederholen
werden
na ja ich verfolge einfach mal weg und
banane griffin zehn leute leben noch wie
sieht man das denn liszt habe ich alles
kein exzess naja verfolgen die beiden
leute ich glaube da oben ist nix hier
wird wohl kaum etwas hey das ist es
kommen die komponente hin
hier ist eine ig zone langfristig gar
nicht bestimmt es hier oben nach ganz
oben kommt man hin
krass ey was bringt das dann wenn man
hier ist verstehe ich gerade in wien
nicht jetzt noch hören dass da oben auch
dass einzelne wolken
ich dachte mir wert sehen was besser gar
nicht ob der debitor noch drin ist
erst gar nicht ob der wortmann mit
aufnimmt
naja das ist hier sonst noch so santa
cruz steht da immer noch um
nein ich habe die truppe verloren die
ich verfolgen wollte fenster mit lu
da kam ein blitz da sind da ist einer
der fliegt auch um das ja hier unten ist
jemand und dahin läuft herum sagt nicht
das ist der typ der sich wieder fit
mennel versteckt er sich der warte
lukas ist ein komischer typ
naja acht leute leben noch nie da seht
ihr auch ganz schön spannend hier
naja ich kann es dir einfach mal so
machen dass ich gerade schnell ist da
fliegt immer noch das banana griffen
wieder okay cool dann nicht mehr zu
begreifen ich denke ich werde gleich die
aufnahme stoppen und euch danach einfach
eine anmerkung rein machen wäre das
alles hier gewonnen hat also ich sage
also eine youtube beschreibung wäre ich
das dann schreiben wir das gewonnen hat
aber dann dürfen los lauf schneller logo
[ __ ] scheiße ich kann schlagen
ich wusste gleich dass ich schlagen kann
und das tut mir leid
das wusste ich nicht jetzt kiste die
schon lernen
der denkt sich wahrscheinlich gerade
höhe deswegen hinter mir hat mich
eingeschlagen
scheiße so wollte ich gar nicht okay gut
also ich denken hast du verdient ich
denke die beiden hier werden dass
gewinne sind sehr gut ausgerüstet haben
auch ender perlen falls es eng wird und
ich würde sagen ich mal ganz kurz
stopp für heute also erstmal danke an
die trave dass ich hier filmen durfte
dank an die gerade dass sie allgemein
ein sehr zuverlässiger server anbieter
sind und uns außerdem auch den server
für die today show für den sponsoren und
allgemein danke an die beiden ich glaube
der eine heißt ja sagt klaus und der
andere heißt lukas aber ich bin mir gar
nicht sicher
naja die tragezeit findet ihr alles und
in der beschreibung gewinne auch eine
beschreibung der zunächst mal
hey leute ich melde mich zurück leif
hier vom standort und zwar habe ich
gedacht okay also ok ich muss euch das
ganze zu erklären wollen euch ja gesagt
ich schreibe euch in beschreibungen wer
gewonnen hat
allerdings bin ich dann essen gegangen
und dachte das ist halt dann vorbei ist
ich komm wir uns sehr hier gerade der
spawn com findet statt
wir sehen hier will lukas und wie sie
laufen hintereinander her wenn ich so
lukas wäre würde ich nun umdrehen sage
ich mal
ja ja ja okay er macht er dreht um oder
er bleibt dort und wie sie läuft glaube
ich einfach nur vor ihm weg du hier war
in us-dollar gesprungen ist gar nicht
jedenfalls ist dass der gerade der sport
kam von den hunger games nitrat von dem
event hier haben wir hier treffen sie
gerade aufeinander das sind die beiden
übrig gebliebenen und lukas hat das
turnier gewonnen glaube ich oder gibt es
noch mehr biss noch mehrere ist lucas
jetzt der gewinner lukas hohly hose luca
soll die rose wollte ok ich glaube es
ist noch nicht vorbei
da ist auch schon der nächste spontan
hatten ein diamant schwert jetzt nimmt
er sich das diamant schwert und hoffen
darauf dass wir jetzt auch sehr
interessant lukas und will lukas
survival games und arena 1 also alles
gute an lukas alles gute an lukas sehr
gut gemacht auf jeden fall super war ein
super event finde ich auf jeden fall
klasse das nicht rolle so etwas
organisiert gekriegt hat und dass alles
so super geklappt hat lukas hat nun
paysafecard in einem sehr sehr hohen
wert gewonnen ich habe
dreistellig und ja ich würde einfach
sagen geht auf die website von radio
wenn ihren günstigen server haben wollt
leicht sie auf facebook alles in der
beschreibung wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal tschüss